we do have former utah congressman and
fox news contributor
jason chaffetz all right jason the
border was an issue before you got to
congress it was an issue while you were
in congress is still an issue
are any of us going to live long enough
to see the border resolve once and for
all
well they should but it's been a lack of
political will the laws are on the books
to actually uh build the border wall to
secure the border to have an entry exit
program and to deny people to just
simply walk across the border but it's
been a lack of political will and the
biden harris administration
in addition to the obama administration
had done everything they can to not only
encourage people but essentially invite
people to come here knowing that if they
do get caught they're going to be
released into the homeland by the tens
of thousands and with the the expiration
of title 42 even though a judge
put that order in place i think there
are still tens if not hundreds of
thousands of people that will be pouring
across at about 18 000 people a day is
the estimate trying to come into our
country in addition to the millions that
have already flowed across our borders
you know jason it's not just the
pandemic i mean it's a national security
issue it's a law enforcement issue do
you think the pandemic is still
a sufficient health danger to continue
triggering title 42
or should they just do as you say and
look we're not going to allow title 42
you're not coming to the country for
other reasons
look it's human trafficking i've talked
to border agents who believe that
upwards of 90 percent of the women that
are trafficked across that border are
raped along the way it's a drug problem
i mean look at the problem with fentanyl
and literally the tens of thousands of
americans have lost their lives so human
trafficking you think that'd be enough
you would think that drugs would be
enough i mean the cartels are
essentially running the border i know
that secretary marcus says that we have
operational control of the border we do
not and it's not just you or me trey
it's the border patrol talk to the
border patrol there's not a border
patrol agent out there that thinks we
have control and that we're doing the
right thing allow these men and women to
do their job repel this invasion push
these people back and get back to the
people you know we're failing trey we're
failing the people that are trying to do
it legally and lawfully those are the
people who are failing
all right on that point i have this
vague recollection when you and i were
there together that you spent a lot of
time looking at fraud in both the
refugee and asylum program so
do i recall that right and what did you
find when you look for evidence of fraud
in those two programs
yeah i was on the immigration
subcommittee there on on judiciary we
looked specifically at asylum and
starting with the obama administration
it used to be that you had to come from
like the democratic republic of the
congo or or south sudan where there's
real conflict think of ukraines that are
ukrainians trying to come they're trying
to flee but obama changed it to hey your
boyfriend's beating you up so you know
that should be good climate change
that's enough to have you come across
the border and claim asylum and it
turned into this massive abuse where you
just see literally streams of people
coming across with notes in their
pockets and they get it out and they
read it and essentially the people in
the united states say well you can be
here you have to go through your asylum
claim and you're going to do that 12
years from now and by the way when i was
looking at it there were only three
administrative judges for immigration in
the entire state of arizona three of
them and they were supposed to handle
these literally hundreds of thousands of
cases it was a joke it was never meant
to actually have the adjudication
process
work so if you utter the right
allegations as as
with respect to asylum then you will
remain in this country until your court
hearing and they may or may not go
looking for you if you were
i think that's right right
yeah not only do you come here then do
you say well the judge has given me a
date and it's years in advance so but
wait i got to work i got to be able to
go to school i got to be able to get
medicine all of which the american
people pay for and so then you go back
to the court and suddenly you have
papers and and so you can go and compete
against americans for american jobs
jason chaffetz thank you for joining us
on a sunday night look forward to
visiting with you soon hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else